okay go theck work so at
this this this is a different starting
point than your Keon wasas right so your
Keon
Wasa with theologically like the myth is
your refer your your point in the
narrative is
somewhere past the actual closing and
engagement and the my um
being altered okay where I know more
about what's happening when we start out
here like in a duel I don't know what's
happening there's anything any number of
things can happen Okay so we want to
remain as neutral as
possible somewhere between offense and
defense uh somewhere between mobility
and stability okay and so to do that my
hands are going to be
up and my
stance is
bladed and the rear heel is off the
ground okay until things start changing
then I start changing my hands then I
start changing my base or what happen
okay and so the drill we're going to do
now is
um understanding more dynamically what
you do in your Keyon at at the moment of
Engagement so the moment of Engagement
happens screw that the I of my hand
because that's the moment of engagement
right there right when he focuses in and
starts his movement towards my hand this
is what my you you were noticing and
what you were noticing is like I'm
starting pre-touch okay so you have to
start pre-touch your relationship is
established
pre-touch all right and so for example
at as he goes and I move I start getting
off the line and start this fight
rotating
likewise here when I feel he has a beat
on me I have to start the fight rotating
you'll take one of those angles to start
this rotation you cannot wait for him to
get into the range where he could use
his line of attack I relate to the setup
of the line of attack okay so I would be
constantly moving as he goes in this
position
I don't want to go back because I'm
going to stay
linear and I don't want him closing on
me and then I move because I have less
options so in this drill it is once you
feel the line of attack being chosen by
him which you determine by his body
language you start the fight rotating
okay for the coach that's your job to
reset that for as as many reps as
possible so he is being trained and I do
this and I set this up so he moved and I
set it up again if the guy is starting
to get it right like okay he got it I
could start thinking ahead and trying to
trap him like a normal person would okay
but if they're not you don't have to go
fast you're just
moving
[Music]
moving moving
moving okay let's
go see like
that see
again there
you be in related to
him and then let him out of the corners
for the drill okay
wow careful with crossing your
feet all
right all right so in in the c c drills
we were doing the other day I was
telling you guys not to wait to full
grip it's too late
pressure is already being
applied it's on my hand right here so as
he seeks full grip I use the seeking to
take him
into whatever Ki angle you want so we'll
go slow make sure you can see just the
handk camera okay so as he's coming in
you see how he went wide there's that
same thing he went wide he could have
gone right
here could have gone right there in
which case he's going to touch me right
here
okay and from that touch he slides to
the
grip but as he's touching and he slides
to the grip I am manipulating him
already
okay if they go wide like he's trying to
get around my hand okay that's what he's
trying to do if he goes wide he's going
to hit solid all at once I don't ever
want that okay so as he goes wide that's
where you see me reach for him just the
SL is touch the finger is going to do
it you see and it come okay
so if you pay attention then I'm I to
start at
contact you actually have to start at
the at the level in intention so for
example in this last one when he went
wide I can tell he's going wide and
you'll see my hand will go to touch him
here are you able to get get that we'll
do it again I can tell because his
elbows
flaring cuz I'm reading the
body and I know
then that and so I'm in a relationship
with him and now I can seek to touch him
as he goes wide I'm not trying to block
him I just touch and as he goes I do the
90° fluctuation and takes him into the
position okay point is even even in
thatal and everything you're doing your
relationship starts at the level of
intention okay so when we're here and
that requires me to read the
body when he goes I pay attention to
things so he already shifted his weight
okay and he shifted his weight that way
when he did that so I would go this way
just ever so slightly I'm reading it he
goes and I come around
okay if I wait and he goes around I'm
close now you see how we got close cuz I
stayed here and then that's what's
happening to you so he goes
back I wait till I see it I try to go
back but he's closer now and then he
comes forward and this is where I get
he's closing on me
okay what I have found over training a
lots of people is you don't trust your
intuition and you it's an obstacle you
you have to trust it you you get a
feeling and you move he might move back
because he knows that's not going to
work anymore that's still works that
counts okay cuz you you stalled his
assault so trust your feeling that you
get when you're going to move don't let
him get those beads on you so that
you're here and you he closed on me okay
trust the movement
boom if i' ever be adaptable
okay try it
again don't square
up don't square
up lot of leg tension all
right
box don't square up don't square
up okay keep going okay get off your
tight rope don't Point your foot away
from the fight your rear foot has to
stay 45 to her angle of attack you're on
the tight rope you're on the tight rope
get some width you're on the tight
rope don't square up don't square up
change directions on him a lot so we see
if he sores up you're on the tight rope
foot is not pointed towards the fight
foot is not pointed towards the
fight use the ball of the rear foot not
the heel of the rear foot don't square
up on the direction
change you're on the tight
rope okay uh
the most neutral you can
be is
toe heel
alignment okay this is your your and and
heels down to be honest so this was Mr
Parker's
stance tow heel alignment heels
down what I am asking you to do is we're
going to slide L curve towards
mobility and we're going to slightly
curve
towards offense in particular counter
offense so I come
out a little wider you see that
okay if I have to be neutral here then
this is as close as my toe in heel can
come into
alignment once I start bringing
my toes into
alignment I'm in that tight rope stance
okay the rear weapons the right cross
the rear front front kick for example
they are out of the
fight tactically because they have to go
around the front weapons by the time
that happens he'll already have entered
closed struck so you in essence have
taken out because of their tactical
importance that's why Mr pick had a
little more slightly curved towards
offense slightly curved towards Mobility
okay so in other words as he comes in to
press all the way he's got to get
through the Trap and the cross and after
you hit a guy like that that wants to
press if you weren't able to close him
and he got back out he starts
hesitating on coming in and the more he
hesitates the worse he is at coming in
and you basically shut down that gate
okay so we want to understand as we're
moving he goes around he's coaching me
that I can only move to tow heel
alignment to his line of attack at the
best we'll go back we'll do that again
again here I am in my slightly more
mobile slightly more offensive stance as
he starts to move if you do put your
heel down here's your line of attack it
has to it can only go widthwise to tow
heel
alignment if he goes around and I go
here I'm to toe alignment to the line of
attack okay I too narrow I've closed
this
off he starts
pressing right and he'll get around that
slight corner of my shoulder I would
have done it with my lead head just get
there and you're there
okay so as you're moving around he's
coaching me he's moving me around look
how I try to keep
it as the original
slightly more Mobility slightly more
offense meaning I move from the ball of
the foot to the ball of the foot and to
slightly wider than tow Hill so we go
he's coaching and you just watch my feet
you
see okay I don't do
this
okay
also squaring up in this part of what
we're trying to train for intention and
reconciling the line of attack at the
moment of intention we with iido
spiraling geometry that's the
drill I want to remain as neutral as
possible so as he's training me I don't
want to change
stance I stay in my fighting stance
which is strong side back weapon back
right uh counter weapon in the front
that's how we that's how we always do it
all right so as he moves I understand
that this gets some
space but in the middle of it nice and
slow you square it up you see and there
was no tactical Catalyst for squaring up
and so all this is is maximum offense
minimum defense and it opens you up to
double legs and things like that okay so
we don't do that in this drill don't
square up so you got to be careful is
that usually it's common place they get
you going one way they change directions
and you step too far around and you're
Square to the line of the
to so he'll get me going one way he
changes directions and I keep the hips
at that 45 to the line of the T he goes
one way
changes directions I never go like this
and then find it again okay all right
fish F try okay watch the watch the tow
heill you got to watch the depth too
there's a depth requirement
wash your toe
heel depth good
better okay and keep that rear foot
angled towards the
fight watch your watch your rear foot
don't let it float out
[Music]
watch the angle on the rear
foot angle on the rear foot don't square
up don't square up don't square
up okay don't no need to let the rear
heel touch the ground right now this
ball ball the ball ball the ball ball
the
ball don't let it touch the
ground he again if we look at
the neutral
bow we take
Parkers there's a depth to it okay and
remember it's your knee hill alignment
so I'll try to do it here
okay it's it's made for your
body so if I turn my body
square and I kneel down this left heel
is going to be in alignment with this
right
knee that's where the ball of that foot
goes if you're too narrow or too
shallow I go and measure again I don't
have knee heel lot okay
so if we take Mr Pig's stance which is
mine it's a little deeper it makes up
for the fact that I'm emphasizing
Mobility I get a little more stability
this
way that would be your Max and knee heel
alignment would be your
minimum just like tow heel
alignment is your minimum for
width we here
okay slightly wider all it there's a
minimum in other
words there's also a foot angle minimum
it's
45° is the
minimum turning your foot
out is way past that okay like in other
words how far can my foot turn out it
can only turn out
45° to obey the foot knee quad
line 45° I'm in Han me on my chest right
now it's 45 deges to line attack if you
start turning this past
dot you see and you come all the way to
over here and you're fighting a guy over
here you now have don't have the quad
knee foot alignment do you see that okay
and that happens all the time in body AR
too right so someone's going to throw
simple technique and this rear foot goes
like
this you see this is out of the fight
this is out of the
fight
okay because I turn my foot in more on
my
throws I can get near that 90 as my
Max with my 45 my minimum okay does does
that make sense when I throw
okay here you are you're trying to
follow those rules
dynamically and
usually it's the foot yet has not
learned how to get connected to the
quad so as he's going one way let's say
he's going to his right it won't
happen because you're stepping it it
tends to happen the other way as he goes
to my left
it drags like the friction of the mat
starts to drag it you see and so now
you're going to move it and drags it it
drags it
open in this
drill you got to keep that minimum
45 and likewise there I don't
ever let the map manipulate me I pick up
the ball of my foot and I put the ball
of my foot back down every time so he
goes one way the ball of foot moves he
goes the other way the ball of foot
moves
okay if I have to trade weight
distribution which sometimes happens to
change direction the other ball of the
foot will be up okay that that you can
do that but you we in this drill we
don't want to be flat heeled so towards
that
end as let's say he goes that way and
this was supposed to be ball of the
foot he goes doesn't go heal ball of the
foot okay cuz for that Split
Second you're over here not following
the rules to the line of attack I'm way
more towards the 90 than I am towards
the 45 on the line of attack okay so
make sure that you stay on the ball he
go goes it's always the ball the
ball okay make sense all right likewise
in terms of depth you have to watch just
as you have to watch that you don't
Square your hips as you don't let that
foot drag out that you're not heal
healing it you also have to watch that
you don't violate knee heel alignment as
your minimum depth this is not good for
you okay meaning as he starts to go I
don't ever go to
there we do it again so you see it a
little more Dynamic this is where you
usually see it
well that in that moment that was that
was wrong you guys see that you're doing
a kind of Step
Shuffle step here well in this moment
that's it you you lost all your
offensive capacity so so you have a
couple
options step he presses step there I can
go wider I don't want to go shower if
you're like I have to move my front foot
then they kind of move together you see
that but the only time you would have to
do that is why you're late you're late
okay so if you read the intention I can
move I'll just take just watch my feet
camera okay he's training me and I just
keep that as I'm going I just keep the
stance as I'm going the foot angle the
hip
angle okay try to minimize the heel
touching the squaring up the getting to
the maximums of this stuff as best you
can nobody's pressing each other hard
it's happening because we're not
responding to the intention okay all
right let's try that so let's say he's
coming in we've closed to within Arms
Reach and he comes in for the double leg
okay and we have a technique
where we
spraw got
it so a little more dynamically you
good and
we okay
or we're in
the
guard okay and uh we have a knee pull so
he's trying to keep
posture
i knee pull in to keep them low so he
can't
strike okay got the idea
or
uh I ski here goes
Kitty and then I do my Maia tou got the
idea
okay all this looks like if then
mentality if he does this then you do
that right what's hidden in the if then
mentality is the mistake of waiting till
touch to estab waiting to full grip to
establish the
relationship okay you're not acting at
the level of
intention any
counter that you
do as you learn in an if then
modality any counter and application is
all that much better if you do
it with other tactics that make his
tactic difficult to succeed okay so for
example as he's going for the double leg
if I'm moving
the sprawl he gets he gets less of me do
you see the sprawl is much easier to
do in other words the harder I make his
the less I provide the ideal environment
for his tactic the more viable my
counter technique is to that tactic
okay so that's what we're doing here if
you stay here he has so much advantage
on
me but if I'm already decreasing
it at the level go slow slower at the
level of intention you pay attention my
body's moving my body's moving and this
becomes easier to
do
okay so if we take katatori
a lot of times you're
here that would be wrong under this
premise okay or a lot of times you guys
will see me you see I already
moved because his intention to establish
the 126 line already manifested and the
back leg already moved so I don't have
to go here and then do this this is not
going to transfer to application Phase
so if we doing a few reps you see I
moved I established the relationship to
the other side you see it's already
there
similarly if he wants to
grab to hold to either strike or to now
clear and get his double leg as we'll
work with that okay so he grabs he
clears double leg there it
is okay so we're here boom hop
boom same thing level of intention not
the same not the same thing at all now
do you see to get his double leg he's
going to have to
turn that's an extra beat on there okay
go back to
here be strong don't let me have it
don't let me have it you see we do the
other one he
goes very weak because we're at
the Young line already the other one
he's in here
okay so this is why I don't do that and
I already moved at the level of
intention I'm already okay so your goal
here is he's going to try to grab either
hand it doesn't matter if it's overhand
if it's underhand if it's on the inside
if it's on the outside it does doesn't
matter okay but you're doing the other
drill okay but they're going to press a
little cuz they have all the advantage
on not letting you strike they're going
to eventually close and they'll box you
in eventually but you're going to be at
an angle and try not to be at the 180
for them okay so the drill looks like
this you go those
boom just get out of it you'll find it's
much easier if you're at an angle when
you get out you don't really even need
fancy stuff you do need though that
you're
working against the thumb opening you're
always working against the thumb open
okay whichever way it
is you guys understand okay so you do
need that in other words you go here you
can't go like that cuz you're into the
fingers so if you're doing the dancing
drill it's his job to get a
hand okay all right try it
go okay so it's at the level of
intention that I'm moving okay that I
move right so he's and that and that's
where I'm not in here and he grabs me
straight with all this mechanical
advantage I started with quiet
rotating centrifugal energy is affecting
him right and I have to I'm adding
quarter turns in essence to everything
he's trying to do okay that way he
doesn't grab from the front you see and
he's right there with all his power and
this right cross waiting to get me he's
grabbing more off the angle you see and
so even if you look at this step you can
see that the right cross got too far
behind this front weapon do you see
where where would you like that to be
okay
or you got it but with my movement up
the circle and his mistake to turn the
right cross is just right there to be
angle cancellation on the on the lead
shoulder you see that okay and it could
be small so as he goes to pump up that
was it it will work
okay well likewise as I'm going to the
level of intention as he goes for the
half and you're going to get out of that
grip
more if you start defending the
grip to the pop that you're going to
need you're going to need this pop right
there you see so as he's moving I move
there that's going to be much easier to
get out then you wait for full fruition
even though you were on the level of
intention on the body it's again this is
more difficult to get out okay so you
can add that too as go he's going to
eventually
close and you rocked that now he's got
to really try to get the grip and what
really try means is he's going to give
up more of his neutral neutrality his
base his balance his inertia his
momentum all that kind of stuff and
that's what you want okay so for
example if I try to do the knee pull
here and he's much stronger than me I'm
not going to get him resist it don't use
your whole muscles can't get him but as
he goes to stand up and I know he's
standing up it's easy peasy
okay so the more I do amidst his
technique prior to full fruition the
more his tactic gets compromised the
more my defense becomes
viable understand so you still might get
grabed
but they had to give up a lot more to
get that grab and that's what we want
okay so in this one as they're trying to
knock you grab at the level of intention
and they start counter the grab at the
level of intention I want you to really
start now trying to get those grabs okay
all right go for
it
good good
it's about the
angling
good
good okay so let's slow it down so we we
have a physical conditioning limitation
here but you are carrying extra weight
there vouching okay so uh don't don't go
so fast okay more conceptual
okay check the angles when he gets a
beat on you just change
directions and and he's going to
eventually close you you just keep
angling
good
boxer there you go just angle on
him and take a
break angle angle angle angle angle
angle there you go that was a good
one good good angle out
happens good angle try to relax more you
you you got to you got to love this
space time switch
rolls you know what I mean
like you're going be a
warrior you got to love the human be
human okay
go you guys keep training I was vouching
take a
break angle angle change directions once
she gets the intention there it's coming
straight so if you're going on One
Direction on the circle and you feel her
get a bead on you then you got to change
directions on the circle
okay you went back you went back so that
worked because you did a single lunch do
you see that and we don't no one does
single lunges but Point Fighters okay
your job is to keep closing your job is
to train her so here you take
this and so I I watch she keeps making
her feet go together okay but you can
see how easy cuz there's no counter I
can just walk here you
see
so so I see her going in One Direction
I'll make her change that was a long
time to change okay this should have
happened
already there you
go
good
good okay and then I can just walk in
good good now be relaxed cuz look how
fast am
I right just
here
angle it was on I caught her on the line
and I got too good grip
okay try again angle
angle
good out comes hand
angle so go
back look how you're angling which way
do you want to
go come on try it
again
cool
no wash my body I go I went here
yes yes you see I go here which way is
it going
yeah that's where you want to go you see
that so that's what happened on the last
one so you you are at an
angle but not to my line of attack cuz
it's coming in this way now it'll be
weak you see and last time you came this
way ever so slightly ever so slightly
now I have a full last grip on me okay
so pay attention to this
part and even as they grab pay attention
so would took two steps to get to the
outside so that's probably not it okay
so do you understand what I'm saying
okay you got to feel what's my shoulder
doing on the
attack
good good there you go that was a good
one okay try it again
little
more good good
okay I want Andrew I want you to try to
get it more not not that one half ass
attempt failed back back out that's not
your training job here okay you you are
going to go flying past him do you
understand he's he's doing it right
you're going to miss radically
okay good
good
good good and see if you can go in for
the double leg same thing you're going
to see what's going to
happen
good good